when you think of making money using
stocks during a recession your first
instinct is to buy low and sell high as
a result many people look for the market
the bottom before buying into stocks
however it's actually possible to make
money on the fall itself entering the
market high and exiting low so how
exactly does this voodoo magic work
[Music]
well it's action not voodoo magic and it
is one of the most basic methods in the
financial community there are actually
two main methods to accomplish this
which are trading options or shorting a
stock options trading is more common
knowledge and something you have
probably heard of an options contract is
basically an agreement to buy or sell
stocks bonds or other securities that
are future day at a predetermined price
typically an option contract is composed
of 100 shares of the same stock or
security an option contract is made with
two parts
I'll call option and a put option these
were basically the buyer and seller for
instance let's say we have Disney stock
that is currently priced at $150 the
call option is the buyer and the
contract gives them the right to buy 100
Disney shares at $150 at a future date
maybe six or twelve months later the
pull option is the seller side of the
contract and the contract gives them the
right to sell 100 Disney shares at $100
to the buyer at a future date as you can
see the buyer is expecting the stock
will go up while the seller is expecting
a stock to go down if the stock goes up
to $200 the buyer will benefit by being
able to buy the stock for the cheaper
104 killer price similarly if the stock
goes down through $100 the seller will
be able to benefit by selling stock for
$150 however either side can back away
at any time but backing away would mean
paying a small fee relative to the price
of the stock to the other side there's a
lot of financial jargon going on but
basically with options you're simply
betting on if a stock will go up or down
and there's not much risk as you could
always back out for a small fee but the
main problem with using options during a
recession is that it will be very hard
to get someone on the other side you can
bet that Delta will plummet all day but
it doesn't matter unless you can get
someone to bet the contrary and that's
where the second method comes into play
shorting a stock this is literally when
you get in high and get out low this
process starts with borrowing a stock
from a broker and yes this is something
you can do
but you will have to pay them a fee as
well as interest on the barbed stock
using the same example as last time
let's just say that fees and interest
come out to $5 you start out by
borrowing a Disney stock that is
currently worth $150 and right when you
get it you sell the bar stock for $150
after that you wait for the stock to
drop to your desired amount which let's
say is $100 at this point you buy the
stock for $100 and give it back to a
broker along with the $5 fee in this
scenario you would make $45 per stock so
if you're short of 100 Disney stocks in
the same way you would have made $4,500
obviously you can scale this up to
millions of dollars and make millions
literally buying into stocks on a
downfall but why would brokers do this
sure there you have five dollars in
interest but don't they lose a full $50
in Disney's talk about you well the
thing is this talk isn't theirs either
it could be but it usually isn't they
take this talk from people who own
Disney stock on their platform and then
lend this out this is not a risk to the
real owner of the stock because they can
still sell the stock at any time and
their platform whether Robert or weebo
will take the loss but clearly it's in
the trading platforms of best interest
to five people who aren't likely to sell
to do this they simply take stock out of
owners who have owned the stock for a
long period of time as in several years
these individuals are clearly long term
buying all investors and they aren't
going to sell based on economic cycles
usually they already bought in quite low
for Disney this might be an individual
who bought into Disney when he was at
$75 trying to sell at 150 and then rebuy
a 100 just isn't worth it for them
because a lot of this money will be lost
to capital gains taxes so as long as
they believe in the company long term
they just hold on to stock expecting to
reach the 200s as you can see everyone
benefits here the bind hole investor
isn't taking any risks and staple trade
on the platform for free the trading
platform is able to make interest on
these talks and continue operation and
savvy investors
make money on a company's downfall and
growth but of course you should be aware
that the savvy investors are taking the
most risk they lose money if the stock
goes up or doesn't go down low enough to
cover the interest and fees so casual
investors should stay away from this and
concentrate on just making money long
term this strategy is generally most
beneficial for very experienced
investors with large funds and
institutional investors these guys
literally bet both ways to minimize
losses let's say there are 75% sure that
a company is going to lose value they
will invest 75% of the allocated funds
for the company on shorting stocks and
25% into buying regular old stocks this
way if the stock goes down as expected
they make 50% profits but even if it
goes up they only lose 50% however as
you can see it's still quite a risky
move so us normal folks should stay away
but that's how the pros we specialize in
this area make money on stocks losing
value if you guys thought this video
explained options trading and shorting
stocks well then make sure drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one